so
uh do you want to see one of our heroes
is this gonna be a real hero yeah this
is a real hero this is a
teacher i believe uh
and this is an organ and there's the
there was a
there was uh demonstrators that were i
think standing you know it's a
demonstrating obviously as as the name
will imply
and here's what this uh molder
of a young children's minds did check it
out this is reasonable i think this is
very reasonable
check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
who cares that's a bad but
that's a bad thing if you're a teacher
and this is how you're handling it
listen teachers teachers are
basically you know those teachers that
are teaching in school
that didn't even go to college yeah
they're called
teachers it's a high school entry-level
job
uh you you have to go get licensed and
go to some schooling for it but
being a teacher being a cop being a
soldier
being all these things right you're
literally ged or higher
skilled workers now i get it being a
doctor is an admirable professor being a
teacher on some level is an admirable
profession if you care about what you do
and you care about the children
and you try to make a difference in
their lives sure
but none of you are important i need
this i need you
to absorb this into your brain none of
you are special
none of you are unique okay i don't care
if you're a teacher or a cop or a
[ __ ] garbage man
you're all at this you're municipal
workers that's all you are
you're not stop calling doctors and
nurses frontline workers
and stop calling cops heroes stop it
stop okay uh like dick said one time uh
on his show cops are basically garbage
men for people
it's it's for all cops exist for all of
us that don't want to deal with a
situation
with a person and you go just call the
cops like they're human garbage men
and and teachers are babysitters with a
lesson plan that's all you are
so i can people
just agree at least through christmas
to let me have my hatred of if you guys
want to go back in january to go like
merchants
i don't know what marsha's problem is i
need you all
to just let me have my hatred through
christmas
can that be my christmas gift from you
people because i i
this is this every day there's a new
video like this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i am enjoying how powerless she feels
like the more she
kicks and screams and the less people
care nobody this this woman here
laughing is
probably my favorite right now see that
chick and her boyfriend seemed like
those two
two people i'd go have a drink yes the
woman right over that
full screen people can see the woman top
left is just that smile on her face was
like
[Laughter]
yeah why are her wipers on because she
probably hit them when she was yelling
and she didn't realize it
or maybe she just got brand new rain-x
blades and you gotta you're supposed to
wipe them a couple times yeah to get
them going yeah
but she's got a lovely face i just got
new wiper blades the other night and i
had to do that while i was driving and
it was no rain and i was like they're
gonna think i'm drunk
like i was driving through striving to
go get food or something
the only car on the road
i'm like they're gonna think i'm
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hammered
okay nobody gives [ __ ] what you are
she keeps saying it like she's an fbi
agent no
right it's like she keeps saying it with
the
the level of authority like imagine if
you're in the mall
right now crowded mall at christmas time
and shots ring out right
and then suddenly there's that one guy
that's like i'm with the fbi
everyone get behind like you know with
that authority she's a teacher
and i'll i will bet you cash money
i will bet you cash money that this
teaches something super worthless she
teaches like fourth grade
or she teaches like seventh grade
english
or something that's so elementary
that it's like i guarantee you if you
looked into this woman
her [ __ ] resume would be laughable
no they're not statistically speaking
your students parents are probably not
dying
[Applause]
you know i'm getting real sick of tasha
rose over here she's really got to cut
it out
this is like mirror universe yeah
bizarro
me have family members died
[Applause]
[Music]
bye bye
see you later by the way it is kind of
funny to think of this just the pizarro
version of
tasha rose because yeah tasha rose would
be the one that goes in the store and
like ma'am you have to have a mask and
you'd be like get the [ __ ] out of my way
i gotta buy artichokes
i'll [ __ ] get out of my way
uh message i received from a sixth grade
english teacher at carmody middle
school you disgusting racist
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] charter schools get
out of our state
jeffco educator freaking teachers are
looking crazy
they have always been pieces of [ __ ]
they really have always been pieces of
[ __ ]
this teacher was uh in jefferson county
school district was placed on
administrative leave monday after a
viral video posted sunday show were
yelling at anti-protesters
in depth she was placed on
administrative leave or
she should have been that's that's like
you still need to [ __ ]
have some sense of decorum right you you
can't
like if you work whether it's for the
private sector or the public sector
there is a certain expectation of like
you can't just do that
you can't you can't just be a lunatic
like you're representing us here and you
know that one of her you know that one
of her kids
saw this right you know that one of her
kids had to have seen it
let me see if i could if i could find
this story
jefferson county teacher placed on leaf
for yelling at protesters
a teacher in jefferson county school
district was placed on administrative
leave monday after a viral video
posted sunday showed her yelling at
protesters in downtown bend
in the video which had 1.6 million views
twitter monday morning the teacher
screamed their protesters to kill
themselves
while sitting in her car she also
identified herself as a teacher gave the
protesters the middle finger and yelled
at her students and families the school
district was investigating the situation
while the first the first year teacher
this is her first year too
remains on leaves superintendent you
know first year
superintendent ken partial has declined
to name the teacher
or state which school or state which
school she worked at
how much you want to bet though it was
below it was below eighth
i am she's a first-year teacher dude
below eighth grade i'd say though she's
definitely
she's definitely one of those [ __ ]
worthless teachers
because there are some teachers out
there that teach some really wild like
you know that there's advanced teachers
there's like algebra
there's stuff that i could respect
because i barely understand it
but like most most of you teachers the
bulk of you teachers are
completely useless and if you think you
[ __ ] aren't going to get
replaced by robots too
oh my god do you even understand how
much easier it would
be to build a robot that can teach
seventh graders
as opposed to a robot that can build a
car
from scratch or a car that can or or a
robot that can [ __ ] unload an entire
ship at the docks
it's actually harder to it's harder to
build that robot it's easy to build a
robot
that goes i before e except after c
but unless ending in a as in neighbor
and way
that's the follow-up that that's going
to be the follow-up to como's robo-woman
it's going to be robo teacher look
people keep asking me what are we going
to do with the [ __ ] robots
i've told people once we hey
once we i like this is this is my cuomo
impression everyone does the ao but i do
the condescending cuomo
hey listen if you can't understand this
then i'll explain it to you one more
time we're gonna make the robocop movie
what what the hell do you think we're
gonna do with all the leftover robots
we're gonna troll them out what are we
crazy
spent millions of dollars on that robot
we're gonna make them teachers